foreign
[Music]
well hello everybody we're very thankful
that you decided to tune in today to
this q a program I'd like to know
you know as I travel different places I
hear people say that this is their
favorite program of everything we do
here at Secrets unsealed and some TV so
we've given some thought uh to the idea
of increasing this program to an hour a
week instead of a half an hour
we are seriously considering that we
haven't decided to do it yet but we have
so many questions that perhaps that is a
good idea I want to give you the email
address where you can send us your
questions you'll see it on the screen TV
at some tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org we would be delighted to get your
questions however
remember to have the patience of the
Saints as the Book of Revelation says
because we receive so many questions and
we do careful research sometimes we take
an entire program to answer one question
that your question might be delayed in
that being answered but it is in order
of that we received it and we are going
to eventually get to it Lord willing I
have with me uh David Salazar who joined
our team quite recently we're very
pleased to have him with us he actually
spearheads the Latino Channel and the
programming there as well as doing I'd
like to know in English and doing
Sabbath school lessons in English you
know here at Secrets unsealed we do many
different jobs
we don't have just one restricted job
the Personnel just basically learns to
do everything amen thank you for being
with us uh Pastor Salazar thank you
Pastor for having me here in this
program and it's a blessing to share
this time and of course to to study
together from the word of God praise the
lord well let's begin with the word of
prayer if you would pray absolutely then
we'll delve into our program absolutely
let's pray Heavenly Father we are once
again delighted to come to you in prayer
to seek the wisdom that comes from you
and from your throne of grace we are
limited in understanding but we know
that as we seek through your word and as
we ask for the Holy Spirit you will lead
us into all truth and we pray that the
answers that we will provide will not be
our own words our own thoughts but will
reflect clearly what your word means and
what it really wants to teach our
friends that are listening and watching
I prayed all this in Jesus holy name
amen amen
well uh Pastor last program there was
one question that we did not answer
correct uh it was actually from
Gladstone
who wrote to us from South Africa and I
think that we need to dedicate just a
few minutes to try and answer that
question basically the idea is that uh
the Garden of Eden was the most holy
place of the sanctuary
and what could we say about that idea
that has become prevalent uh in many
circles in the Adventist Church well
pastor we know that people take that
idea on the fact that they and he
actually quotes Genesis 3 8 where it
speaks of the presence of God was
visiting them the couple you know Adam
and Eve and then uh also they I suppose
they take the idea that it was the most
holy place for the fact that after they
were expelled from the Garden of Eden
there were two children that were placed
in the entrance and so with that
they may say okay that's the most holy
place but I believe that we are really
just coming to an assumption not really
a clear specification from the word of
God and will actually make it very clear
that I that we will not support that I
view uh for one thing remember that
wherever the Lord
is wherever he comes becomes holy you
know so the idea that his presence makes
a place holy it's not new and it's a
matter of fact when he is presented
himself to Moses by The Burning Bush
when Moses was close to that area the
Lord said remove your sandals because
it's a Holy Ground
the presence of God does make a place
holy but to be the most holy place as
they're trying to imply would mean that
somehow the garden meeting was part of
the sanctuary or the uh Tabernacle that
the Lord himself pitched now bravely in
Hebrews 8
verses one and two we actually hear from
the inspiration of you know by Paul by
the Apostle Paul writing to the Hebrews
that the uh Now read this it says now
the things which we have spoken this is
the sun we have such a high priest
speaking of Jesus who is set on the
right hand of the Throne of the Majesty
in the heavens a minister of the century
and of the truth Tabernacle which the
Lord pitched and on men and verse 4 it
says for if he were on Earth he should
not be a priest seeing that there are
priests that other gifts according to
the law in other words
if the Tabernacle the truth Tabernacle
was ever on earth then Jesus could not
have been the high priest but because
the Tabernacle is in heaven the
sanctuary the whole Most Holy place is
in heaven Jesus you know uh can be the
high priest of such high Tabernacle or
the Tabernacle so uh I guess I will say
that from the spirit from the word of
God I mean we will not have that
evidence at all that there was a holy
place there it really they wouldn't
connect to the concept of the Tabernacle
in heaven is part of the uh or the or
the a lot of it and he's part of the
African Heaven it doesn't really connect
but you have also something to share
about that first prophecy I believe yeah
there's a clear distinction between the
Garden of Eden
and the sanctuary in heaven they're not
the same thing
um and the evidence for that is uh in a
quotation that we have here from
Adventist home
uh page 539 paragraph one right the
Garden of Eden remained upon the Earth's
long after man had become an outcast
from its pleasant paths
the Fallen race were long permitted to
gaze upon the home of Innocence their
entrance barred only by the watching
angels
at the cherubim Garnet gate of Paradise
The Divine Glory was revealed hither
came Adam and his sons to worship God
here they renew their vows of obedience
to that law the transgression of which
had banished them from Eden
When the tide of iniquity overspread the
world and the wickedness of men
determined their destruction by a flood
of waters the hand that had planted Eden
withdrew it from the Earth but in the
final restitution when there shall be a
new Heaven and a new Earth it is to be
restored more gloriously adorned than at
the beginning
so very clearly there's a distinction
between the Garden of Eden right and the
sanctuary right because uh you know
there is a sanctuary in heaven like you
read from the book of Hebrews and
there's a Garden of Eden in heaven which
are two different things correct uh so
uh very clearly
um although there appear to be some
parallels like the cherubim who guarded
the entrance to the garden and God
walking through in the midst of the
garden uh in the cool of the day there
might be some parallels but I don't
think that you can take those parallels
to a state that uh that the Garden of
Eden was the most holy place on the
sanctuary absolutely and the idea of a
century was for the dwelling of God uh
for his presence to be there permanently
that's what it was placed on Earth the
Lord visits them there and there is no
evidence as you mentioned that they had
anything to to do with the sanctuary in
heaven that was made by God and was made
for the purpose of the role of Jesus for
priesthood for being a high priest that
doesn't really connect with uh
praise the Lord for that furthermore
furthermore when Lucifer was in heaven
yeah
um he was the governed cherub
which means that the most holy place was
in heaven exactly not a nurse that's
that's very clear and and so uh and so
to to
take the most holy place and located on
Earth
uh when the Bible says that sin
originated in the presence of God
we might say in the most holy place in
the Heavenly Sanctuary right uh I think
is a stretch absolutely absolutely
that's stretch thank you for that
um pastor and so we'll continue with the
next question and this is a very
interesting question that comes from
Kelly
we don't know where she's from but uh we
like to know if the next time they can
send us a location it's always good to
know where friends are from she asked
the question about uh the Sabbath and
the question is is if the Ten
Commandments are Eternal how did the
Sabbath commandment exist in heaven
so I suppose that her question is how
can the Sabbath exist before man was
made
well let's first I guess try to go to
the verses in the Bible that talk about
the Sabbath you know what the Sabbath is
there is an interesting verse in Mark
that the Lord speaks to us in regards to
what the Sabbath is and
um I have to have it right here uh
okay here is uh 2 27 and 28 yes that's
another one yeah so you can read that
one I I missed it somehow and he said to
them this is Jesus speaking the Sabbath
was made correct for man yes and not man
for the Sabbath therefore the son of man
is Lord is also Lord of the Sabbath so
the Sabbath was made for man correct in
other words Sabbath has an Earthly Focus
absolutely and that's a thing you know
we have to now how we reconcile this
concept that the server was made for men
as Jesus clearly said
Eternal and the Eternal you know law
means that is as old as well not all
because it always existence so is you
know as as the Lord has existed so has
his law how can we reconcile those two
uh Concepts how the Sabbath existed
before being made for men
yeah
the bottom line is that the Ten
Commandments uh are Divine principles
the principle we find behind the Sabbath
commandment is respect for the Creator
recognizing Christ as the Creator
that is the purpose of the Sabbath every
seventh day we are commemoring that
Jesus is our creator we're remembering
that he is our creator so we don't
forget right now God can test people uh
whether they recognize Christ as a
Creator or not in different forms but
the principle is the same right for
example he tested Adam and Eve with a
tree right at the end of time he's going
to test uh the world with the day of
rest so so in other words the principle
behind the Sabbath commandment is
respect for the Creator and remembering
the Creator now could there be in heaven
what was the test for the angels to
recognize Jesus as their creator correct
because Lucifer said he's just like me
and so that was there so to speak tree
of knowledge of good and evil or their
Sabbath which was to test their loyalty
to the Creator uh does that mean that
the Sabbath does not exist in other
Realms I wouldn't go that far
I now I'll give my personal opinion you
know when when I have a personal opinion
and I don't have a thus say of the Lord
I'll I'll say it I personally believe
that God has synchronized the universe
so the Sabbath Falls at the same time
every place
now I don't have any proof of that but I
believe that the Sabbath is that has
been the test
even before the creation of this world
however
inspiration what I can say for sure is
that Mark chapter 2 verse 27 says the
Sabbath was made for man it was the test
for man whether he would recognize his
creator or not amen I think that it's
very
uh wonderful to know that the revelation
of the law of God to us humans to us
here on Earth it's really the revelation
of his principles as you mentioned and
the principles that the law
call its health or is founded upon are
the principles to love and honor their
creator love God and love our neighbor
love our fellow man and these principles
were greeting out
for in order language for our own
understanding and beyond that we really
can't make any sense you know
assumptions or you know guarantees or or
assurities but at the same time we can
certainly believe that the principles
will be Anar forever for everyone in the
universe with that instead as you
mentioned
um the idea the Sabbath will be kept
also
when we go back to heaven so the fact
that there will be Sabbath keeping in
the new Earth uh you know it will give
us a you know it gives us an assurance
that the Sabbath has been
uh made from the foundation of the earth
and before that there has been plan for
that whether or not that is as you
mentioned your personal opinion it's a
it's a guarantee we'll have to see in
heaven you know but it does have a lot
of sense to it in the sense that if the
Lord will give us a Sabbath in the
future maybe we'll understand that it
was actually you know throughout history
but that again we cannot 100 say it with
us at the Lord yeah uh obviously it's
going to be an eternal sign in the
future right because we're going to go
from Sabbath to Sabbath as you mentioned
to worship before the Lord we're also
going to go from month to month yeah now
the question is do other worlds have
months
do other worlds have a seven day week
you know those are questions that we
cannot answer here yeah right we have to
trust in the Lord someday we're going to
have an answer however the the Fantastic
thought is that this little world is
going to be the capital of the universe
right
God is going to transfer his
headquarters from Heaven to this earth
the New Jerusalem is coming here and the
Throne of God is going to be here right
and it is here that we're going to go
and worship before the Lord every month
and every week correct and so uh you
know whether other worlds observe the
sabbath that we do we don't know for
sure yeah but there is some way that God
tested them to see if they recognized
their creator and they remembered their
creator yes and and it's very important
that we keep in mind that we know what
is revealed to us for our own benefit or
salvation sometimes going Beyond those
limits can be dangerous and is not
necessarily uh too relevant for our
Salvation you know trying to find out
certain things that we might not be able
to know for sure but at least we know
from what you mentioned we have shared
that the Sabbath is a principle that
will be kept throughout eternity you
know that's a blessing well I hope that
this has been uh somewhat enlightening
we probably have not answered the
question fully and completely because of
a lack of because of a lack of
information
but someday we will know I praise the
Lord yes I know we like to do that but
we have to be limit to what we can say
and that's the Lord you know so it's
important uh we have now another
question pastor and this is a very
interesting question from progress
Temple he's from Zambia Africa we are
delighted to have his question in our uh
list here it says uh help me understand
what the scripture means in first
Timothy 4 4 and 5. so the question he
has is to explain First Timothy 4 4 and
5 and I'll read the question and and let
you start the answer Pastor he says
there for every creature of God is good
and nothing to be refused if it will be
received with Thanksgiving for it is
Sanctified by the word of God and prayer
so what can you say about this question
I know that I've I've met a few people
who use this question to speak about
certain foods specifically you know that
if you just pray for over it you can
either identify you can eat everything
how can you answer this well uh you know
people for example people who like bacon
they're going to look for justification
in the Bible to eat bacon you know even
though in God says in Deuteronomy 14
Leviticus 11 don't eat pork yeah the
Bible is explicit in that yeah and it's
not a ceremonial requirement it is
actually has to do with health right
these are Health laws pork is not good
for you
and uh and we need to read the entire
passage in order to understand what it's
saying uh so I'm going to begin at verse
1 of chapter 4 First Timothy now the
spirit expressly says that in latter
times
some will depart from the faith giving
heed to deceiving spirits and doctrines
of demons
speaking lies in hypocrisy having their
own conscience seared with a hot iron
now verse 3 forbidding to marry
would that be contrary to the Bible yes
forbidden to marry yes
uh why would it be contrary to the Bible
who established marriage the lord well
so they're forbidding what God
instituted right okay that's the key
forbidden to marry and command it to
abstain from foods which God created
to be received with Thanksgiving by
those who believe and know the truth now
we need to find out
what foods God made or created right to
be taken with Thanksgiving exactly so
let's go back to Genesis 1 29 right and
that's the key understand what the Lord
made for a sweet Genesis 1 29 says and
God said behold I have given you every
Earth bearing seed which is upon the
face of all the Earth and every tree in
which is their fruit of the tree
yielding seed to you it shall be for
meat
okay so the question is what foods did
God created for us to partake with
Thanksgiving fruits nuts and you know I
will say vegetables things that are made
for our consumption that did not involve
any killing okay any thinking of Life
all right now
um this makes it a lot easier to
understand verse four right for every
creature a better translation is every
creation right every creation
of God is good
and nothing is to be refused
if it is received with Thanksgiving now
when it says
every
creation of God is good and nothing is
to be refused if it is received with
Thanksgiving does that mean uh that uh
it's okay to get drunk with alcohol and
be an alcoholic everything God created
you know it comes from grapes right uh
is good uh does it mean that we can eat
pork because you know God created pigs
obviously they didn't come by by
Evolution or anything so is that what
it's saying no
what is it saying that every Creek every
creation of God
which he created to be partaken with
Thanksgiving yes that's the kind don't
take it out of context correct you know
everything that God created is good and
you can eat anything you want that's not
what it says everything God created
for the purpose it's good he's good
according to the previous verse right
and so it says uh for every creation of
God is good and nothing is to be refused
nothing of what he created to be eaten
the context uh
if it is received with Thanksgiving for
it is Sanctified by the word of God and
by prayer you know somebody said uh that
when you sit down to eat a pork chop you
can't pray and Lord bless this which
thou Hast cursed
because in Isaiah 65 66 is there's a
curse upon those who eat big so so you
know it's a text taken out of context
for a pretext to eat what you want to
eat and people will be a lot healthier
if they did not eat pork absolutely
there is a there was a person that I
know that or my wife actually met that
she will say if bacon Is Wrong I Don't
Want to Be Right
and you know that is yeah the idea a lot
of people you know they are they cling
to their their likes their taste buds
and they don't really wanna
learn from the word of God and rather be
an error and that's the truth you know
it is a funny saying but at the same
time is is sadly you know they don't
want to be right and so we got to say
Lord help us to understand from the word
of God what really that means and as we
you have explained pastor and thank you
for sharing with us this uh connection
it's really important that we give
thanks and we pray for the things the
Lord has Sanctified to be eaten for our
benefit yeah right you know it's
interesting uh I had an interesting
experience my father was president of a
conference and he had a treasure
who was uh not real strict when it came
to health uh principles of the church
and they would travel a lot and they
would stop along the way and they would
eat in a restaurant and so one day they
ordered fish now that in my my dad at
that time ate fish because down there
you can get nothing but if you're gonna
eat all you can get is white rice with
an egg on top so there was no interest
in vegetarianism at that time or
veganism of course and so they ordered
fish and when they brought the fish you
know they had a word of Prayer and uh
when for for God to bless the food and
uh my dad started looking at the fish
and he says uh you know I don't think
that this fish has scales and the Bible
says they're supposed to have scales we
better ask the waiter what kind of fish
this is and uh the the individual was
with my dad says yeah ask him after we
ate
so that's a case of of wanting to do
something and and not wanting anything
in the Bible to reprove what you're
doing yeah and so you know we need to go
to the Bible yeah with an open heart
with sincerity absolutely and not try to
input our wishes and our desires and our
tastes on what the Bible says and you
know pastor this is something that I
think is you know you can sing by
being ignorant or choosing to be
ignorant you know about something
specifically I remember going as you
mentioned I had a friend who would go to
a particular restaurant a lot and uh the
first time I went with him I said have
you ever asked he ordered
something that you know like mashed
potatoes or something like that you know
old vegetarian
but I said have you asked if they make
this with uh lard you know which is pig
fat or not he says no I've never thought
of asking that question I said well look
um it's better to ask you never you know
you're never gonna be afraid of you know
or wrong if you ask so he agreed to ask
you know or you know wait till because
he already ordered food I said let me
ask the waitress so I I called it just
said listen we are you know we believe
that we shouldn't eat anything with pig
and or you know lard or something like
that so I asked her if that was you know
made or used for the making of the food
and she said let me go back to you on
that
so we waited and this is favorite
restaurant and so after she comes back
she says unfortunately yeah it has lard
you know these everything had was made
with that and this is in the South so
you can imagine
so uh he's like man you're ruined for me
my favorites and I said well listen you
know I saved you you know yeah in the
sense that and this is a thing I mean he
joked about it but it's true sometimes
we cannot just be you know blind to the
fact that maybe some of the things that
we're eating are poison our bodies and
the Lord is giving us the the knowledge
of the truth to be able to do a research
to find out to ask questions if we need
to and and I know that it may seem wrong
at first but I believe that as we
ask questions and we you know tend to uh
be open about our beliefs people will
actually be interested in knowing why is
that they believe this way and we showed
to the Bible and and I've never had a
problem honestly in all my life asking
questions nobody has said other one in
my house anymore or anything like that
you know the Lord has given me the
chance to be able to connect with them
and they learn the truth through me
asking questions
you know um
when I go to a restaurant
that serves refried beans yeah
I always ask whether they have lard
because it's very common to put lard in
refried beans because it makes them
smooth right and I learned my lesson
long ago that I needed to ask because
anything with lard in it and of course I
don't eat lard right but once in a while
you'll ask and they they'll lie they'll
say oh no no it doesn't have any lard
right and it really makes me sick to my
stomach right if if it happens
accidentally and so when I go now to
those restaurants that serve refried
beans
I say
do these beans have lard
and the person says no no they don't
have lard say because I get really sick
if I eat anything with lard
and then they're afraid of getting sued
and so they make sure whether the beans
have loud or not that is true that is
true you know I tell you in my in my
when I go to some Latin American
countries I actually have to ask in a
way that seems like I'm interested
because you know and they say oh yes he
has them and I'll be like okay thank you
like you make these beans with large
right and they're like if they say yes
yes I do I'm like okay thank you and
usually it's because they tend to lie
sometimes like you said pastor so it's
important that we ask and you know those
questions but amen praise the Lord for
that well we are thankful that we have
been able to uh be with you and for
sharing this important aspects and
questions you have please send your
questions we look forward to answering
them may God bless you and your family
as you search from the scriptures
[Music]
foreign